we've been talking about the enormous
scale of the crisis here in houston and
it's clear by the size of the rescue
operations the coast guard has deployed
more than 500 service members to texas
and more teams are on the way here crews
have saved more than 2 000 people so we
got a rare look inside the coast guard's
houston area command post and saw true
teamwork in action
before the coast guard rescue teams can
get to work outside is she in
contractions right now they get their
marching orders from inside this command
post headquarters i'm going to get more
details on her later
this center is an operations hub for not
just the coast guard but for local law
enforcement and the national guard as
well recently we have transitioned to a
call center which is back in our
conference room you mean you've had so
many calls coming in you've had to set
up a separate call center yes ma'am that
is correct we've had everything from
senior citizens with kids trapped in
attics with only two feet of clearance
left before the water completely floods
the house we have other people stranded
in vehicles the task seems overwhelming
it can be at times yes
overwhelming too for rescue pilots
working in the pouring rain
this is air station houston where
they're working around the clock to keep
the helicopters running what's the
biggest challenge for you as a pilot
i think the biggest challenge would be
the weather right now
with the fly really low to the ground a
lot of us aren't familiar with area we
don't know where the antennas are you
know where there's power lines how risky
is it
it's very risky captain kevin odett is
the incident commander in charge of
running this entire operation they're
operating in visibility less than a mile
in some cases winds gusting over 30
miles per hour it's very dangerous
but the risks and the rescues continue
how would you describe the situation out
there
i would say there's a lot of people in
trouble rescue swimmer graham mcginnis
and his team helped save a family of
three on sunday but first they had to
get them to the only safe place to land
this highway we had to cut through a
chain link fence to get out to the
highway and in about 30 minutes we were
able to get out to the highway and get
her loaded onto the helicopter for some
in the coast guard this is a crisis that
literally hits home we have coast guard
members that have been impacted by the
storm as well
some of them have had been flooded out
of their homes in my home as well i had
my street i had three feet of water in
front of that my house so
we're concerned not only about the
public but also about our coast guard
members we want to make sure that
they're safe as well
now the coast guard says it has deployed
a total of 20 helicopters from all over
the u.s more than 200 crew and support
staff there are also nine shallow water
rescue teams working with eight more who
are on the way so as these rains
continue and as harvey is expected to
come back and deliver some more rain
these efforts continue to save lives but
it really was remarkable to see sort of
behind the scenes at the coast guard i
heard it from people here
who've been rescued by the coast guard
they're just absolutely amazing people
and they are risking their lives to save
lives gail maurice okay nora
extraordinary work being done there
thank you so much for the inside look